now of course crazy stuff happening in
the news but there's some news
that's getting a little buried with
everything that's happening with
president trump not wanting to concede
maybe he's never going to leave
and our republic will collapse little
things like that but there's other
news apparently there was another recall
of romaine lettuce
due to e coli bacteria yeah small story
but
i should mention it now this sort of
thing
seems to happen almost constantly
doesn't it we're always hearing about
these
recalls of lettuce because of e coli
well guess what we have a brand new
sponsor
and they finally solved the problem this
is exciting it's pretty cool
take a look yet another e coli
outbreak in romaine lettuce it feels
like there's a recall
every week aren't you tired of never
knowing if
or when your romaine has e coli
well with constant coli romaine lettuce
you'll never have to guess again because
our romaine
always has e coli guaranteed
mmm romaine lettuce in a delicious
caesar salad
absolutely packed with e coli
and every head of constant coli romaine
comes with
a recipe for grandma's tainted lettuce
wraps frequently asked questions about
acute kidney failure
and tips and tricks for dealing with the
diarrhea
all right now we're talking constant
coli
romaine lettuce
[Music]